like what what barriers do we need
removed because that's my statement I'm
not I'm not stating anything else I'm
stating women versus men it's very silly
like so so what bears
it's not a fair question it's how is it
not a fair question at proving the point
of why what people especially black
women other people who are anybody who's
not white why we hear feminism and we
don't want that label because it means
I'm just gonna say it means that like it
means that you're you've already gone to
a pinnacle of whatever you think your
happiness needs or whatever your
survivalist needs are when there are
people on lower end who are trying to
survive who are trying to get to a point
of what should be normal
um based on what other people have it
sort of sounds like you're saying
feminism is not always inclusive then